oh they just want to see VIN and Statham
that's it end of story
yeah didn't State them Vince I didn't
nobs shop hi there reject nation I'm
Greg Alba T Erickson it's T Erickson T
Erickson yeah
does Erickson mean anything is it really
good me except for if I took the key out
it's a phone company I have a K in my
name so we're still on that so you're
not acknowledging my question I don't
know what it means strong powerful
unique loving caring popular loved
superhero and humble well at that what
is your name mean Alba oh my last name
hey that's a beautiful name wow there's
a hot actress out there limited on
acting talent I'm usually associated
with her movies that are most
anticipated of 2020 this comes from the
channel looper let's see if terror will
still be alive by next year to watch any
of these films and then we'll talk about
which ones we are most anticipating 2020
might feel far away but Hollywood's
major studios are already planning ahead
and it's looking like it could be an
incredible film industry here are the
most hotly anticipated movies coming out
next year seven years after the return
to produce the project directed by Adil
LRV ends in lawful law bad boys for life
has been a long and difficult journey to
the big screen and many fans thought
that it would never even happen
especially when the movie was pulled
from the studio's release schedule and
lost its initial director due to
scheduling conflicts but it appears that
it's finally moving forward now and
should mark a fun new opportunity for
fans to enjoy the action Adventures of
Smith and Lawrence
once again we may not have any specific
details and the movie's plot yet but
literally bought this thing the
follow-up to 2014 Spectre has endured
his rough road as any franchise his five
decade history it was uncertain for a
while if Daniel Craig would even return
for his fifth onscreen mission of
Trainspotting director Danny Boyle
initially took and then promptly stepped
out of the director's chair now however
some details about double-oh-seven
25th cinematic outing are finally
becoming clear Craig will indeed return
one last time in a film by true
detectives cary fukunaga the first
american director to helm a Bond movie
intriguingly one earlier is America
distinct back and forth critical
reception middling reactions to Quantum
of Solace inspector punctuated
overwhelming acclaim for casino royale
at Skyfall so following that pattern
this movie is set to become a rousing
success important details such as the
film's title and who will perform the
theme song have yet to be announced but
we do know that bond 25 will hit
theaters on Valentine's Day 2012 cardi B
doesn't do the theme song to be pissed
with pleasure
[Music]
I love it routing it up for Marvel's
guardians of the galaxy movies vintage
is shifting gears for a different sort
of comic book film The Fast and Furious
actor will step into the lead role in
Sony's upcoming bloodshot movie adapted
from Valiant Comics successful comic
series of the same name the lead
character is a wounded soldier who's
been resurrected through the wonders of
nanotechnology and now he has to hunt
down powerful outcasts called harbingers
the comic premiered in 1992 and ran from
110 issues with upwards of 7.5 million
copies sold now the success of violent
comics derived films like Logan and
Deadpool valiant and Sony will surely be
striving for an R rating given this
heroes taste for blood we'd expect
nothing less blood shot will be helmed
by visual effects artists and first-time
director Dave Wilson and will co-star a
Segen solace Michael Sheen Toby Kebbell
and Sam Hewitt and is due out February
23rd good actors fans may have to wait
an extra year for Fast and Furious 9 but
they'll get a spin-off movie out of
Dwayne Johnson and Jason Statham in the
meantime and Hobbs it shot of my tickets
finally does hit theaters in the spring
of 2019 although we don't know much
about where the main sagas headed next
the pressure to keep upping the stakes
should mean it'll find a way to be even
more epic and ridiculous than any of the
previous installments with Charlize
Theron cyphers still alive and on the
loose at the end of the fate of the
Furious there are plenty of existing
opportunities for vehicular mayhem you
can probably count on most of your
favorite cast members returning - and
the franchise's you see these movies by
all means there's always not know
everyone even more big names to join the
cast announced in Furious night is due
for release I love that variant like
that first film fans will finally get
the answer to an age-old question may
22nd to 2020 when Godzilla and King Kong
faceoff on the big screen director Adam
Wingard is already assured fans that his
take on the two monsters will crown a
definitive winner
unlike the 1962 film that first put the
two characters against each other this
will be the fourth entry in the
legendaries and monster vs. winner
Eevee's won't speak their name but i
call them skull crawlers why because it
sounds neat
further expanded on with Kong Skull
Island Godzilla king of the monsters
will open that world even wider in 2019
bringing old favorites like Mothra and
Rodan into the fray and setting the
stage for this next Clash of the Titans
Godzilla vs. Kong is the body this video
is kind of old movie will also feature
an impressive lineup of human actors
stranger things Millie Bobby Brown yeah
she doesn't mean much as America with
Black Panthers Danai gurira in Deadpool
twos Julian Dennison also attached to
star audiences haven't seen much of
Angelina Jolie over the past few years
in fact her most recent big-budget movie
was 2014's Maleficent now after four
years of waiting Disney hasn't really
heard of the fairy with the horns and
the high cheekbones she's not there some
personal white stuff reproduction she
only role as Maleficent and Aurora
according to the synopsis sequel began
several years after the first chapter
and follows the complicated relationship
between the orange fairy and the soon to
be Queen hot off her appearance and
Edmund and the wasp Michelle Pfeiffer
has signed on to the project as Queen
Ingrid Dickinson third in the epic
series trust will step in to replace
Brenton Thwaites as Prince Phillip
Aurora's love interest did require the
actor directed twenties pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales will
venture into the Enchanted Forest and
Hellmouth feature which is set to hit
theaters on May 29th 2017 s Wonder Woman
is the most critically acclaimed movie
in the DC extended universe by a very
wide margin it makes sense then that gal
gadot next adventure as the Amazonian
service talked to the big screen while
Superman and Batman are left a struggle
against a legion of issues and
complications standing in the way of
their next movie appearances well this
is the days when mom's biggest concerns
were exploding windup
Dianna's second solo story hasn't been
without its own delays however
Wonderwoman 1984 was pushed back from
its original 2019 holiday season release
to June 5th 2020 when the movie does
finally arrive it will likely bring with
it just the kind of colorful blast from
the past its title promises filling in
part of the timeline between the first
movies wolf and one sitting toe Wonder
Woman 1984 we'll see the return of get
ducks Chris Pine decide that way if
that's the right way to say it mr. Blake
also joins with Ray as nemesis in the
depths of the Soviet Union way pretty
hard to keep a movie production secret
for very long especially in the modern
age that's why it was so shocking when
filmmaker Jason Reitman revealed that
not only was he working on a new
Ghostbusters movie but then he already
had a vague but atmospheric teaser
trailer already announcing it's summer
2020 arrival the son of original
Ghostbusters director ivan reitman jason
has formed his own identity as a
director with such offbeat low-key drama
DS as Juno and Tully now he's ready to
direct and co-write a new chapter of the
story he watched unfold on set as a
child Gale Canaan the director of 2015's
poltergeist remake will be sharing
writers different writers pretty a
plenty of reasons for fans to be a
little frustrated with Paul Feig 2016
Ghostbusters reboot but it's still a
bold move for reitman to return to the
original timeline he explained to
Entertainment Weekly it's not a reboot
what happened in the 80s happened in the
80s and this is set in the present day
it remains to be seen who else will be
involved Harold Ramos passed away in
2014
Rick Moranis is in semi-retirement and
Bill Murray has long been slippery on
the topic of committing to another
sequel but then who really knows what
Bill Murray could do at any given moment
[Music]
Kozinski
oh god maverick timing Top Gun maverick
2020 follow-up to 1986 his classic
flyboy thrill ride this new installment
will find the original movies hero
taking the son of his fallen friend
under his wing Top Gun director Tony
Scott had once envisioned a sequel to
his original movie but his death in 2010
put those plans on hold producer Jerry
Bruckheimer remained dedicated however
eventually hiring Kaczynski and securing
the commitment of original stars Tom
Cruise and Val Kilmer miles teller will
play the son of goose with Jennifer
Connelly Jon Hamm and Ed Harris also
joining a cast a big part of Top Gun
success was its wildly popular
soundtrack so it's lucky that harold
faltermeyer is also returning to compose
the score with Kenny Loggins recordable
you just asking yourself oh my god Kenny
log on June 27 is still one of the
defining songwriters and performers of
his generation not only did he earn a
Pulitzer Prize for the monumental impact
of his Broadway musical Hamilton but
he's also been a delightful presence of
family film and television meanwhile
director Jon M Chu is best known for
forging a cultural phenomenon in 2018
with crazy rich Asians combining these
two only be a great idea maker that's
exactly what's gonna happen in 2020
choose adaptation of Miranda's debut
Broadway musical in the heights the
Lewis has been revealed about the movies
during a movie adaptation of mr.
personick American residents of
Washington Heights neighborhood of New
York City
Miranda himself originally played the
central role of who snobby a young
bodega owner who dreams of returning to
his familial home of the Dominican
Republic after a long and troubled
development history that stretches back
a whole decade in the heights will
finally hit screens on June 26th the
crimes of Grindelwald may have been
cursed with the less anticipate but
nevertheless continued the Harry Potter
tradition and the rewards of box-office
gold are some reasons a Warner Brothers
JK rowling or director David Yates to
transfigure their plans for a five movie
fantastic Beast franchise and the third
end travels right
they don't need at least Newt Scamander
in company with a number of potential
paths Rijal Harry Potter movies the
fantastic beasts screenplays aren't
adapted directly from books so we can't
be certain just we're rolling we'll take
her Wizarding World next she has dropped
some hints however including the
possibility that fantastic beasts 3
could take place in Rio de Janeiro a few
years after its predecessor we're
getting up roll not too cool cool but
why this first of which will hit
theatres having December 18 Oh idea this
massive undertaking reportedly has a
total budget of 1 billion dollars
allowing director and franchise
mastermind James Cameron to fully
embrace a slew of new technologies to
watch this movie actually stunning as
the first chapter Cameron isn't watching
on the story either and the movies are
said to be a family saga about Jake the
theory and their children much of
avatars cast is set to return with some
making a comeback despite their deaths
in the original film newcomers include
fear The Walking Dead's Curtis own owari
the leader of a clan of reef people in
Game of Thrones
Oona Chaplin as male a playground
character described as strong and she
got stabbed group of young actors will
take on mostly sea dragon roles as the
younger set of pandora residents
bringing a film a whole new challenge
and hopefully some new life as well
check out some of our newest videos
right here Wow this is like so much of
my life went by and they didn't have the
most recent Top Gun trailer we're just
so good well dude this video is clearly
kind of old yeah this is before this is
pretty common 2017 yeah those are
January 2019 I was like seven months old
Wow you know still rolling eyes I don't
come on this channel very much relevant
we get a little late to check-in out
certain videos that's why we have the
tile because in case we suck at
something we just go a little cold this
is before Comic Con and the talk on
maverick trailer I feel like kind of
stole the shin terms of the trailers
that came out that was just an awesome
awesome
trade allure yes it was you have a
reaction for it yes I do be still my
beating heart I love you so much Tom do
you know it's funny about Tom Cruise I
watched that going clear documentary
yeah called you one right and in this
political climate we have over taken
down celebrities even I am like yeah I
don't care about that stuff put me in
all these movies it's weird I am guilty
to just being like yeah I don't even
need to know if that stuff that really
happened did I love him you could hate
on me all you want
you know majority of the people that's
the sad part I'm just pointing out what
everyone else doesn't so today I was on
Instagram I had the thought of like what
happened to the actors kelly mcgillis
she was such a big part act like Top Gun
and then I saw this photo it was a then
and now photo
oh god of 1986 and 2018 and then here it
is on screen for you guys right now let
me show it to Tara
that's a row right oh my god no
see if Tom Cruise had got an older like
actually looks
oh they gained weight this wooden looks
it's only it looks bad by comparison if
you think about it oh my god
I think that's when the producers and
Tom Cruise were like yeah we're gonna
get Jennifer Connelly instead she says
she doesn't care to be involved in it at
all she's like she's that like she can't
she had a we don't like responses like
I'm all them over way now I don't even
have interest in this I didn't expect
them they'll reach out to me for I don't
think she acted after that right I have
I have no idea
[Music]
looks the same he looks totally the same
she looks a few years older there's sort
of things you could say off-camera that
you can't say on camera bad boys for
life I'm excited for this have yeah the
bad boys yes it was one of my favorites
right the only thing that worries me
about it is this a January release and
sometimes a January release means they
don't have faith that this would
actually be a good movie but Will Smith
January I feel like that's almost a
guaranteed hit for him Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence and it's not gonna be a
lot of competition in January for them
Will Smith isn't as consuming sure is a
Latin movie just made a billion dollars
but that's really the property of
Aladdin and not just Will Smith actually
well let's knock Jack's royal like
there's a lot of concern about his
Gemini man movie if that's gonna be a
hit but bad boys for life put that in
January when nobody has money after the
holidays it's gonna make at least 250
dollars first day
guaranteed and Will Smith could use that
money he is struggling right now I've
talked a lot about this bond 25 film
lately they already have b-roll footage
release of them filming in Jamaica I did
not realize it was that's a great
Jamaican impression this is how white
people interpret Jamaican culture yeah
you think it's very good yeah Saban 25
first American director I didn't know
that no wonder the films have been so
flip-floppy ah always go American
alright watch once this film was great
very good if you want to get a good
British spy movie get an American
director always okay we know what we're
doing we do better than in Brits better
than anyone else you're smart I the
Americans they really know how to do it
right dialogue and film they know how to
do it
something all sound and the Jamaican
woman was even more accurate thank you
so much
fast and furious 9 sure why not okay
we're moving on Scylla vs. [ __ ] I wasn't
a huge fan of the storytelling of
Godzilla
maybe the martyr's but I thought the
fight scenes were beautiful and at bay
yes Kong Skull Island I had almost the
exact same feelings about I liked the
first Godzilla movie what I liked about
this piece of news though is that
they're saying that Godzilla vs. Kong
will have a definitive winner because
most of the time in these verses movies
they [ __ ] out
oh they're versing but they're gonna
have a common enemy or something in the
finale of the film that they're gonna
have to band up and go at it right yeah
exactly it's important that we see who
comes out on top I'm personally hoping
it's Godzilla
we've just had more investment in
Godzilla the fact that he's had two
movies yeah in this whole franchise true
I just want Godzilla to win I feel like
it would just be fair I just like to see
the light come up and out of him you
know what I mean that's the most
exciting part like let's just blow up
some stuff with that blue fire stuff you
got coming out Godzilla
you know Kong he's got fists and hair
cool I mean he's just like any other
dudes you know be cool if Godzilla or
blue lights him and he's set on fire and
then you get like a fire Kong and you
get like fire or you get like a ball
because it's completely no air that's
the only way I want to see Kong come out
on top one room in 1984 we've talked a
lot about on this channel yes we're
excited who wouldn't be Ghostbusters
reboot you know what interests me about
this is the fact that Ivan Reitman no no
Jason Reitman yeah the son of the
director of the first cursed crazy is
doing this you know this Ghostbusters is
kind of a weird franchise to me yeah how
hardcore the fandom is for ghostbusters
yeah I've never quite clicked with that
fandom because I mean you've seen
ghostbusters yeah like it's a great
comedy it's a funny film I know there's
been like games and stuff I didn't
really feel like that was super relevant
to
being ghostbusters it's like the Jim
Carrey movies of the 90s had shows there
was like an Ace Ventura cartoon and
stuff so even the female Ghostbusters
movie came out I was like oh wow there's
like this whole crazy dedicated fandom
for his mother's I did not know about
what's underground where you don't
belong
no I belong on top in the spotlight yeah
god I'm like so cautiously excited about
this I think it's more fascinating to me
to know that the son of the yard
originally on this who has proven
himself to be a wonderful director
different kind of comedies that yeah is
gonna be doing to me more than actually
the Ghostbusters coming back I'm more
interested in yeah yes I wonder if he's
like take that dad yeah take that my
deceased father he's like you did it
good but also me too
let me do it better fantastic baby Spice
3 and Avatar - I'm not excited for
fantastic piece 3 because the fantastic
piece 2 crimes occurred and the wall was
easily the most sluggish experience I
had last year oh my god you guys that
was like a growl sneeze that was weird
I'm okay improvising holy water really
it doesn't look like holy water what is
that it looks like you were like shaming
it looked like you were shaming me well
part of anything Catholics do in
ceremonies they're doing the holy water
and shaming same times I get it avatar
anyway two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve I can count
to Gregory we'll see in the heights
tonight though lin-manuel Miranda I
haven't seen Hamilton how do you mean
either I would liked his Evan I would
love to see you see Hamilton anybody out
there you got Hamilton Tigers you give
me the Hamilton understand what I'm
saying to connect with the New Yorkers
out of there
get my hands on some tickets to Hamilton
I saw monarch in Knights her beer
enthusiast was so funny in that multiple
episodes in Kerber Tuesday oh cool I
didn't know that and in the Hyde's I
think that's cool that he's not doing a
movie at of
of the one that made him of make estar
he's doing to the first loosen I'm was
good back then obviously noticed it now
I'm still good before and I want more
people to see my roots that sounds cool
I'm Jon Chu crazy rich Asians one of my
favorite movies of last year yeah
that sounds exciting you went back to
his roots like his first video no one
would be like really make that you don't
I mean but Lin you're like yes do it
because his talent and him here he's a
blog that knows a lot about movies names
directors and actors producers and
writers I can say other things true but
running out of time it's like looking at
comments in a humanoid version so fun
for you right yeah it's so fun like I
slap in the face you're the best person
to bring on the channel slap in the face
you want a fresh one
well guys with twenty twenty movie are
you most excited to check out comment
below subscribe to the real rejects
check out Tara on her youtube channel
click that of please hey Tara
yeah you want help yeah yeah Tara's
handling the patient the day shadows I
throw you a bone this time throw me a
bone
we got a Tristen Tyler Haig or Luke
Anderson which one you want to go Luke
Anderson Luke Anderson yeah his dad is a
holy man as a pastor I believe okay his
name sounds like milk like a brand of
milk okay a manager at FedEx think Tom
Hanks at the beginning of castaway like
that kind of guy where he's like like
you know the trucks and the deliveries
and marching orders yeah sure he seems
nicer than that let's go with that
I haven't heard from him in about six
months but he's got his card on file now
say whatever you want Luke Anderson
listen you remember that milk it was
named
Anderson mil pol milk right Anderson
where you and your dad in the milk if
not it's alright okay so listen stop
barking the orders on all these FedEx
guys right they're out there they're
working hard for you I see you get them
a Starbucks card five bucks don't go any
more than that and you did just need one
coffee right get it for all your drivers
and I tell you your life is gonna be so
much easier after that right manager of
the year I love them so much they're
gonna be walking around going Luke Luke
Luke I would too if Gregory gave me
Sarah's card right now I'd be like
Gregory Gregory oh well then you'll have
a song at work you'll be the best
manager they ever have in the history of
managers and then also you'll probably
have enough fame then to start back up
Anderson milk this is good I think I'm
just gonna get the list for Desmond just
shoot a bunch of events yes slap
shouldn't meet Gregory I'll do him I'm
gonna change this award here to Terra
Aries to give you a pitch in the bidet